mais de sonner l'alarme
et de promouvoir le changement.
Que ce soit de droit ou non,
notre position dans la société nous rend très crédibles
et nous ne devrions pas gâcher cela.
Je regrette de ne pas avoir pris la parole au Zimbabwe,
et je me suis promis
qu'en tant que Commissaire à la Santé de la ville de New York,
j'utiliserai toutes les opportunités que j'aurais
de sonner l'alarme
et d'obtenir du soutien pour l'équité sanitaire.
Je dénoncerai le racisme,
et j'espère que vous vous joindrez à moi,
et je me joindrai à vous pour dénoncer le sexisme
ou toute autre forme d'inégalité.
Il est temps de nous lever
et, en tant que communauté, de dénoncer
les inégalités structurelles.
Nous n'avons pas besoin d'avoir toutes les réponses
pour appeler au changement.
Nous avons seulement besoin de courage.
La santé de nos patients,
de chacun d'entre nous, en dépend.
(Applaudissements)